This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，培养心理坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《2%》。也就是数字2的“%”。在《回看当年》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我而言是一个重大时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。1984年是一个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学步》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就非得这么做。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。我的脑子炸裂了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。
New listeners, old listeners, wherever you're. are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today's episode has a little bit less to do with psychology and more so to do with the 20s component. Our health in our 20s is kind of a little bit of a black box. We have a general understanding of how to be healthy and how to be well, but there is kind of a mystical nature to exactly what we should be doing, what we should be eating, what we should be consuming, how much exercise we should be doing, what is the right balance to strike between having fun and taking care of ourselves. And there's a lot of lingering health
新听众、老听众，无论你们身处世界何地。很高兴大家能回来收听又一期节目，当然，我们将在节目中剖析二十几岁的心理学。今天的节目与心理学的关系稍微少一点，而更多地与20多岁这个年龄段本身有关。我们在20多岁的健康状况有点像个黑匣子。我们对如何保持健康有一个大致的了解，但对于我们到底应该做什么、应该吃什么、应该消费什么、应该做多少运动、在享受乐趣与照顾自己之间如何把握好平衡，似乎带有一种神秘的色彩。而且还有很多挥之不去的健康
questions. How are the behaviors that I am performing now going to show up in my health in 20 years? Is that something I should even care about? Simple answer is yes. But if you have ever wanted to just sit down with a doctor and say, tell me what to do. tell me where to start, tell me where to go. Today is that perfect opportunity. I had the absolute pleasure of getting to interview and talk to a leading medical professional, a leading doctor, Dr. Mark Hyman, on all of the best health tips he would personally recommend for people in their 20s. Without further ado, Dr. Mark Hyman, it's so nice to meet you. Can you introduce yourself to the audience? Yeah, hi, everybody. It's Dr. Mark Hyman. I'm a physician. I'm a,
问题。我现在做的这些行为，将在20年后的健康状况中如何体现？这甚至是我应该关乎的事吗？简单的回答是：是的。但如果你曾经想过和一位医生坐下来，对他说：“告诉我该做什么，告诉我从哪里开始，告诉我该去哪里。”今天就是一个绝佳的机会。我有幸采访并交谈了一位顶尖的医学专家、顶尖的医生——马克·海曼医生，探讨了他个人会向20多岁年轻人推荐的所有最佳健康建议。废话不多说，马克·海曼医生，很高兴见到你。你能向观众做个自我介绍吗？好的，大家好。我是马克·海曼医生。我是一名内科医生，是一名……
a practicing doctor, a sort of advocate and practitioner of functional medicine. I'm an author, written 15 New York Times bestselling books and basically focused on addressing the root causes of disease rather than just treating symptoms. I spent my whole career helping people optimize their health through food is medicine, lifestyle changes, cutting-edge science, and my goal is really to help people live longer,
一名执业医生，可以说是功能医学的倡导者和实践者。我是一名作家，写过15本《纽约时报》畅销书，主要致力于解决疾病的根本原因，而不仅仅是治疗症状。我的整个职业生涯都在帮助人们通过“食物即药物”、生活方式改变和尖端科学来优化他们的健康，我的目标确实是帮助人们过上更长寿、
healthier, more vibrant lives, and understand how their bodies work and give them the basic manual for their body, which they didn't get when they were born, and understand when you understand how it, functions and functional medicine, you can make it function better. And that's really the whole goal here. I love that. They didn't get the guidebook when they were born. Certainly didn't get it in school. I feel like people are still kind of scrambling for how to look after their bodies.
更健康、更有活力的生活，理解他们的身体是如何运作的，并为他们提供一本出生时没有拿到却属于他们身体的基本使用手册。当你理解了身体的运作机制和功能医学时，你就能让它运转得更好。这真的是这里的全部目标。我喜欢这个说法。他们出生时确实没有拿到指南。在学校里肯定也没学过。我觉得人们仍在为如何照顾好自己的身体而手足无措。
And that's why we all get pulled in different directions by different information. But some things are definitely certain about what's good for our health. Can you give us like a little list of what is like approved like exercise sunlight i mean you know it's i always joke that i get paid a lot of money to tell people do the most obvious simple things that work and i and i i don't know why we don't realize like we we spend millions and actually maybe billions of dollars on pet food that just the perfect food for our dogs or cats and we understand that we shouldn't feed them mcdonalds and a big fries and a coke but we feed them to our kids and so we knew they knew exercise we i mean to take they're dodged to the park if you have a pet. And so we have this intuitive sense of what's good,
这就是为什么我们会被各种不同的信息拉向不同的方向。但对于什么对我们的健康有益，有些事情是绝对确定的。你能给我们列一个小清单，列出那些被认可的东西吗？比如运动、阳光……我的意思是，你知道的，我总是开玩笑说，我拿着高薪去告诉人们做那些最显而易见、最简单却管用的事情。我不知道为什么我们没有意识到这一点——我们在宠物食品上花费了数百万甚至可能是数十亿美元，只为了给我们的狗或猫找到最完美的食物，我们知道不应该给它们喂麦当劳、大薯条和可乐，但我们却把这些喂给我们的孩子。所以我们知道运动，我的意思是，如果你有宠物的话，你会带它们去公园。所以我们对什么是有益的有一种直观的感觉，
except somehow we think because we're humans, we're exempt from the laws of biology. And we're not. You know, our bodies are biological organisms. We need to treat them with respect. And when you give them the right food, the right kind and quality of exercise, get enough rest and the relaxation of the nervous system, when you get enough sleep, because there are different things. One is sort of a nervous system reset and one's actual sleep, which is basically made. medicine in itself, and you get some basic support from nutrients, which are lacking in our diet or in our food, then that provides the foundation for most of what you need. And the other piece I would say that often isn't included in these sort of basic lifestyle concepts around health
不知为何，我们却认为自己是人类，就可以不受生物学规律的约束。但我们并不是。你知道的，我们的身体是生物有机体。我们需要尊重它们。当你给它们提供正确的食物、正确种类和质量的运动、充足的休息和神经系统的放松，当你获得充足的睡眠——因为这是两码事，一个是神经系统的重置，另一个是实际的睡眠，而睡眠本身基本上就是一种药物——并且从缺乏的营养素中获得一些基本的支持时，这就为你所需的大部分东西奠定了基础。我要说的另一个通常没有被纳入这些基本的健康生活方式概念中的因素是，
is the power of community, the power of connection and belonging and meaning and purpose, which are more kind of squishy. You can't just go, I'm going to go do a five-mile meaning and purpose run, and just snap your fingers and have instant connection in community. I mean, you know, a large percent of the population is very lonely. And the surgeon general in the United States recently actually wrote a report on the epidemic of loneliness. It's like smoking two packs of cigarettes a day. So that is a really important component of longevity and health. And the blue zones has talked about this. So it's really, it's an important piece of the puzzle. And the problem is Most people just don't even know what the pieces of the puzzle are or how to apply them
社区的力量、连接与归属感的力量以及意义和目的的力量，这些东西更具象。你不能直接说：“我要去进行一次五英里的‘意义和目的’跑步，”然后打个响指就能瞬间拥有社区和连接。我的意思是，你知道的，很大一部分人口都非常孤独。美国卫生局长最近实际上发表了一份关于孤独流行的报告。这就像一天吸两包烟。所以这是长寿和健康的一个非常重要的组成部分。蓝区（Blue Zones）也讨论过这一点。所以，这真的是拼图中的一个重要部分。问题在于，大多数人甚至不知道拼图的碎片是什么，或者如何应用它们，
and they hear so much confusing conflicting information. They don't know what's going on in their body. They don't know how to assess it. The doctors don't know how to do anything about optimizing health. If you go to your doctor and say, I want you to help me create health, they're going to be very confused. You know, come back when you have symptoms. You've got a disease.
他们听到了太多混乱、相互矛盾的信息。他们不知道自己身体里发生了什么。他们不知道如何评估。医生也不知道如何优化健康。如果你去找你的医生说：“我希望你帮我创造健康，”他们会感到非常困惑。你知道的，“等你有了症状再来吧。你得病了。”
I don't know. Your tests are fine. You can't find anything on your exam. So you must be crazy. Here's some Prozac and come back when there's something really wrong with you. And they're missing something. You know, there's a whole syndrome, what I call FLC syndrome. That's when you feel like crap.
“我不知道。你的检查结果很正常。体检也查不出什么。所以你一定疯了。给你开点百忧解，等真的病重了再来吧。”他们漏掉了一些东西。你知道的，有一种综合征，我称之为FLC综合征。也就是你感觉糟透了的时候（Feel Like Crap）。
And most people walk around without knowing they have these subtle imbalances or dysfunctions that we're seeing actually with my new company, I co-founded called Function Health, where we actually can see the level of deficiencies and nutrients. At one moment today, she had low vitamin D. I was talking to her like 20, which is very low. And I, you know, I was just saying, you know, it can make you tired, have brain fog, seasonal depression, can cause muscle aches, can cause even things like it. increased susceptibility cold infections.
大多数人走来走去，却并不知道自己存在这些微妙的失衡或功能障碍。我们通过我联合创立的新公司Function Health实际看到了这一点，在公司里我们实际上可以看到营养素缺乏的水平。就在今天的一个时刻，她体内维生素D偏低。我和她交谈时，她的数值大约是20，非常低。我只是对她说，这会让你感到疲劳、大脑迷糊、季节性抑郁、引起肌肉酸痛，甚至会导致诸如增加对感冒感染的易感性等问题。
And she's like shaking her head like, yep, yep, that's what I got. And here she was walking around as a 30-something-year-old thinking she was great and healthy, living in New York City, trying to live a healthy lifestyle. It was a health reporter, actually, but just had no clue that she had. A health reporter, that's so funny. Yeah, but they just don't know unless you test. You know, you can't guess. You have to test.
她一边听一边摇头，心想：“没错，没错，我就是这样。”而她走在纽约市的街头，作为一个30多岁的人，还觉得自己状态大好、非常健康，过着健康的生活方式。事实上，她还是一名健康记者，却完全不知道自己……一个健康记者，这太搞笑了。是的，但如果你不做检测，你就无从得知。你知道的，你不能靠猜。你必须检测。
And so I think it's really important for people to understand that they need to know what's happening with their bodies. They need to know how it works. and basically, you know, at any point in life, you can hit the reset button and get yourself back to health if you know what to do. This really, listening to you say that is just, A, incredibly powerful. B, I love that you talk about community because obviously this is a podcast for people in their 20s and we talk about it a lot. But C, you can't just start focusing on your health the moment you're diagnosed with cancer or the moment you're diagnosed with some life-threatening thing. and I remember like having something similar kind of happened
因此，我认为人们非常重要的一点是，他们需要了解自己身体正在发生的事情。他们需要知道它是如何运作的。基本上，你知道的，在生命的任何阶段，只要你知道该怎么做，你都可以按下重置按钮，让自己的健康恢复。听你这么说，真的是——A，极其震撼；B，我很高兴你谈到了社区，因为显然这是一个面向20多岁年轻人的播客，我们经常讨论这个话题；但C，你不能等到被诊断出癌症的那一刻，或者在你被诊断出某种危及生命的疾病的那一刻，才开始关注自己的健康。我还记得类似的事情发生过，
where I had this huge health scare and I was like, why is it only a priority now when I could have done so many things that were preventative? Yeah, exactly. That could have stopped me from getting here. Yeah, and the truth is, you know, that the disease starts early on, even in childhood. So whether it's bone loss or cardiovascular disease or dementia or diabetes,
当时我经历了一次巨大的健康恐慌，我想：“为什么它现在才成为首要任务？明明我本可以做很多预防措施的。”是的，完全正确。本可以阻止我走到这一步。是的，事实是，你知道的，疾病在早期就已经开始了，甚至在童年时期。无论是骨质流失、心血管疾病、痴呆症还是糖尿病，
which now, unfortunately, is one and four teenagers, have pre-diabetes or type of diabetes. Yeah, it's pretty scary. What you used to call adult onset diabetes when I was in medical school. And they changed the name to juvenile diabetes and from juvenile diabetes and adult onset to type 1 and 2, which, you know, basically because type 2 is occurring in little children, as I was 2 years. So, you know, these things start early and there are dysfunctions that then don't become, let's say, a disease until later. Let's say you're low in vitamin D your whole life. You might have a little
不幸的是，现在每四个青少年中就有一个患有糖尿病前期或某种类型的糖尿病。是的，这挺可怕的。在我读医学院时，这曾被称为成人发病型糖尿病。后来他们把名字从青少年糖尿病和成人发病型改成了1型和2型，你知道的，基本上是因为2型糖尿病现在正发生在小孩子身上，甚至才两岁。所以，你知道的，这些事情很早就开始了，有些功能障碍在后来才演变成某种疾病。假设你一辈子维生素D偏低。你可能会有一点
low energy. You might be a little depressed. You might have a little muscle soreness. You might have you know, it's just some cognitive issues, brain fog. But it's the thing you think would be like a disease. But then at some point, you know, if you go long enough with low vitamin D like that, you end up with osteoporosis and you break a hip and that's, you know, a serious problem. Because half the people who break a hip when they're older don't make it out the rest of the year. The mortality rate's about 50%. It's worse than cancer. So this is something you could have prevent it if you knew when you were 20, but if you wait until you're 50 or 60, it's a problem. We're even seeing, you know, cancers in the young people now. We're seeing it in 30-year-olds
精力不足。你可能会有点抑郁。你可能会有一点肌肉酸痛。你可能会有一些认知问题、大脑迷糊。但你会觉得这只是一种普通的状况。然而在某个时刻，如果你长期处于维生素D偏低的状态，你最终会导致骨质疏松症，摔断髋部，你知道的，这是一个严重的问题。因为老年人摔断髋部后，有一半的人撑不过接下来的一年。死亡率约为50%。这比癌症还要糟糕。所以，如果你在20岁时就知道，这是可以预防的，但如果你等到50岁或60岁，那就是个大问题了。我们甚至看到年轻人现在也患上了癌症。我们在30岁的人身上看到了，
and even 20-year-olds are getting colon cancer and things that we never saw before because the change in our diet and the antibiotic use and the toxins in our environment and it changes our microbiome. So, you know, it's never too early to start paying attention to your health. Because when you're 20, you feel like you're invincible, you know, and you can just do whatever you want, you can eat whatever you want, you can stay up all night and party, you can drink, you can smoke, you can vape, you can take drugs. And in a certain degree, you have some resilience when you're younger, but you're basically borrowing off your future self. And at some point, your bank account's going to be empty. So, you know, like if you just have a certain amount of
甚至20多岁的人也患上了结肠癌以及我们从未见过的情况，因为我们的饮食改变了、抗生素的使用、环境中的毒素，这些都改变了我们的微生物组。所以，开始关注健康永远不会嫌早。因为当你20岁时，你会觉得自己是无敌的，你知道的，你想做什么就做什么，想吃什么就做什么，可以通宵派对，可以喝酒、抽烟、抽电子烟、嗑药。在某种程度上，年轻时你确实有一些恢复力，但你基本上是在透支未来的自己。总有一天，你的银行账户会空空如也。所以，就像如果你在银行里只有一定数量的
money in the bank and you keep spending it, eventually you'll run out, as opposed to keep making deposits in your health bank account on a regular basis, you'll have plenty of health equity left in there. You know what? The perfect example of this I always think about is my parents and my parents are like the my mom's like 60 and the woman still has a six-pack like she is so fit my dad just set a p-b on his on his marathon time also like 60 and I look at them and I'm like how and I think I compare them to you know other people in that age and all the things that I that my parents have now that make me not have to worry about them started when they were in their 20s and they implemented such a holistic lifestyle.
钱，却一直花，最终你就会花光。相反，如果你定期往你的健康银行账户里存款，你的健康资产就会绰绰有余。你知道吗？我总是能想到的一个完美的例子就是我的父母。我的父母——我妈妈大约60岁了，这个女人居然还有腹肌，她身材太好了。我爸爸最近还刷新了马拉松的个人最好成绩，也是60岁左右。我看着他们，心想：“怎么做到的？”我把他们和那个年龄的其他同龄人进行比较，我发现我父母现在所拥有的一切让我不用为他们操心的东西，都是从他们20多岁时开始的，他们践行了一种非常整体的生活方式。
And back then, that was really difficult. Like to eat organically 30, 40 years ago. Really hard to avoid alcohol. And they're from Australia. You know, everyone's drinking down here. Everyone's smoking. Like, it was really difficult. But it is such a long-term payoff.
在当年，这真的很难。比如30、40年前吃有机食品。要避开酒精真的很难。他们来自澳大利亚。你知道的，那里的每个人都在喝酒。每个人都在抽烟。这真的很难。但它的长期回报太丰厚了。
And it's such a perfect segue into this huge question I want to ask, which is during a period where a lot of us take our, health for granted. And I used to be someone that was included in that. What do you think is one thing that people in their 20s really need to start doing early to see the most successful long-term results? Well, I think, one, I think, you know, all the behaviors around what you eat, exercise, sleep, stress management are critical. I think one of the things that people do when they're younger is they tend to cut back on sleep. They want to party. They want to. They want to party. They want to. They want to stay up all night.
这完美地引出了我想问的一个重大问题：在我们大多数人将健康视为理所当然的时期里（我也曾是其中一员），你认为20多岁的年轻人真正需要从早期开始做的一件事是什么，才能看到最成功的长期结果？嗯，我认为，第一，我认为围绕你吃什么、运动、睡眠、压力管理的所有行为都至关重要。我认为年轻人常做的一件事是，他们倾向于减少睡眠。他们想要派对。他们想要狂欢。他们想要通宵。
They want to just not sleep because they can get more done or they're more functional or be more productive. But at the end of the day, they're borrowing off their future self. And that causes low-grade inflammation, immune dysregulation, can increase your risk of cardiovascular diseases, cancers, and memory loss. So I would say don't skimp on sleep. You'll be more productive.
他们想要不睡觉，因为这样他们能完成更多工作，或者他们觉得这样工作效率更高、更有成效。但归根结底，他们是在透支未来的自己。这会导致低度炎症、免疫功能失调，并会增加患心血管疾病、癌症和记忆力减退的风险。所以我想说的是：千万不要吝啬睡眠。你会更有成效。
You'll be happier. You'll be healthier. You'll less likely crave carbs and sugar, alcohol and have addiction issues. So really important to make sure you get plenty of good quality sleep. And you know, you don't sleep 10 hours a night, but you can sleep seven to eight as opposed to like sometimes people going as a badge of honor. I'm only sleeping four hours a night. And that's like a value proposition for them somehow. But unfortunately it's not. The other thing is, you know, understand the harm of sugar and starch. These are just two things that unfortunately are just
你会更快乐。你会更健康。你对碳水化合物、糖、酒精的渴望会减少，也更不容易产生上瘾问题。所以，确保获得充足且高质量的睡眠真的非常重要。你知道的，你不需要一晚睡10个小时，但你可以睡7到8个小时，而不是像有些人那样把“我一晚只睡4个小时”当成一种荣誉勋章。这不知为何成了他们的一种价值主张。但遗憾的是，事实并非如此。另一件事是，理解糖和淀粉的危害。这两样东西不幸的是在我们的社会中无处不在，
ubiquitous in our society, whether you're in Australia or in America or any Western developed nation, even developing nations are now more and more exposed to the American food supply. And what's happened is that, you know, that's led to an epidemic of obesity globally. There's over two billion people who are overweight. It's more than twice as many people who are hungry every night. Yeah. I mean, think about it. There's more than twice as many people who go to bed obese or overweight than who go to bed hungry every night, which is still a lot. like 800 million people, but it's like, you know, it's like what? We got the math wrong in that.
无论你在澳大利亚、美国还是任何西方发达国家，甚至连发展中国家现在也越来越多地暴露于美式食品供应之中。发生的情况是，这导致了全球肥胖的流行。有超过20亿人超重。这比每晚挨饿的人数多出一倍还多。是的。我的意思是，想想看，每晚带着肥胖或超重入睡的人数，是每晚挨饿入睡人数的两倍多，而挨饿的人数依然很多，
Like, we could have dispersed that a little bit. But yes, I'm sorry, continue. No, it's true. And so I think, I think just understanding that your health is like your bank account. And if you want to, for example, have plenty of money when you're older, I do this for my kids. When they were little, I put money in a retirement account for them. When they were like, you know, babies and, you know, in elementary school and junior high school and high school. and even stopping when they left home,
大约有8.04亿人，但这就像是……什么？我们在数学上算错了。我们本来可以稍微分散一下的。不过是的，对不起，请继续。不，确实如此。所以我想，只要明白你的健康就像你的银行账户。如果你想在年老时拥有充足的金钱，比如我为我的孩子们这样做。当他们还小的时候，我为他们存了一笔退休金。当他们还是婴儿、上小学、初中、高中时，
even then it's grown to an astounding amount of money just by the power of compounding interest and investment over time. And so, you know, you put little deposits in early and you get big dividends on the back end. And so I'm 65 and, you know, when I was young, I don't know exactly why maybe because my sister was in college and I looked up to her and she took me to the veggie room in Amherst College in Massachusetts
甚至在他们离家之后也没有停止，仅凭时间和投资的复利威力，它就已经增长成了一笔惊人的巨额财富。所以，你知道的，你早期投入小额存款，在后端就能获得巨大的红利。因此，我现在65岁了。在我年轻时，我不太确切地知道为什么——也许是因为我姐姐在读大学，我很崇拜她，她带我去了马萨诸塞州阿默斯特学院的素食餐厅，
and they had peanut butter, crunchy peanut. butter and holy bread and honey and I'm like oh this is good I'm going to be a health nut you know so I think I basically started eating healthier I started eating more whole foods although my mother did do a lot of that because she missed the 50s in America she lived in Europe for the whole time and so she didn't really get the whole ultra-process food thing that got happening in America and we just had a garden we had a garden and fruit trees in her backyard in the suburbs when I grew up literally in the suburbs wow and and so I I kind of grew up with that, but then I started running.
那里有花生酱、脆花生酱、全麦面包和蜂蜜，当时我想：“哦，这真不错，我要当个健康达人。”所以我想我基本上是从那时起开始吃得更健康，开始吃更多全食，尽管我母亲确实也做了很多这方面的事，因为她错过了美国的50年代，她一直在欧洲生活，所以她其实并没有经历美国那种超加工食品的盛行。我们甚至有一个花园，在我成长时期郊区的后院里有一个花园和果树， literalmente在郊区，哇。
I did yoga. I made sure I didn't abuse my body with excess alcohol or drugs. And so I ended up having, you know, those investments when I was young pay off now in terms of the level of my health, the lack of any chronic diseases like high blood pressure, heart disease, cancer, diabetes. You know, I mean, most people my age are on like two, three, four medications and have you know, 40% have more than two chronic diseases, probably more over 65. That's the average of the population.
所以我基本上是在那种环境中长大的，后来我开始跑步。我练习瑜伽。我确保没有用过量的酒精或药物去虐待我的身体。所以最终，我年轻时的那些投资现在得到了回报，体现在我的健康水平上，以及我没有任何像高血压、心脏病、癌症、糖尿病这样的慢性疾病。你知道的，我的意思是，我这个年龄的大多数人都吃着两、三种甚至四种药物，其中40%的人患有两项以上的慢性疾病，65岁以上的人可能更多。那是人口的平均水平。
So I think it's like 83% of people who are on Medicare have some type of chronic disease. You know, that's a lot of people who have these issues. And I don't because I just put in these health deposits. I think it's so valuable because when you are at that age, you know, we're in our 20s now. Assuming most people listening to this, you're in your 20s. of course you're going to feel most of us a baseline level of like stamina and an ability to bounce back and all the good things. And then when you're 60, you're still like you're going to be very present at that age. Yeah.
所以我想，大约83%的医疗保险（Medicare）受益人都患有某种类型的慢性疾病。你知道的，有这些问题的人非常多。而我没有，因为我一直在做这些健康储蓄。我认为这太有价值了，因为当你处于那个年纪时——我们现在20多岁。假设大多数听这个节目的听众都在20多岁。当然，我们大多数人都会感觉到一种基准水平的耐力和恢复能力，以及所有美好的东西。然后当你60岁时，你依然会处于那种状态，在那个年龄充满活力。是的。
Yeah. That you had done things earlier. And it's this weird thing I do sometimes in my head where I'm like, would I rather have fun for longer or have really intense fun times now that might not even feel that great? you know, like abusing alcohol. Like really, how, how fun is it to be blackout drunk? You know, how fun is it actually to feel disgusting the next morning? Like, it's actually not that fun. And I want to talk about alcohol consumption because obviously it's such a huge drug.
你会庆幸自己早些时候做了这些事。有时我在脑海里会进行这样奇怪的权衡：我是愿意享受更长时间的快乐，还是现在去体验那种可能感觉并不那么美妙的、极其疯狂的快乐？比如酗酒。老实说，喝到断片到底有什么好玩的？第二天感觉恶心透顶到底有什么好玩的？其实一点都不好玩。我想谈谈酒精消费，因为显然它是一种非常强大的药物。
And I have to remind people of this, like alcohol is a drug. And I still drink. I love a little glass of wine. I love a martini. But what should we be wary about in terms of alcohol consumption in our 20s? Well, you know, it's one of those things that we thought was fine and maybe it prevented heart issues and was good for your heart health.
我不得不提醒人们这一点：酒精是一种药物。而且我还在喝酒。我喜欢一小杯葡萄酒。我喜欢马提尼。但在20多岁时，我们在酒精消费方面应该警惕什么？嗯，你知道的，这曾是我们以为没问题的事情之一，甚至可能觉得它能预防心脏问题，对心脏健康有益。
And we had a whole story about it. But that was based on population data. But when you start really looking at the science and there's been reviews of the science, and again, the Surgeon General, they'll kind of head doctor of America. But I report on the linkage between alcohol and cancer, which is increasingly clear that there is some link among many common cancers. I mean, just for women alone, if you have one glass of wine a day, which is not excessive,
我们对此有一整套说法。但这基于人口数据。但当你真正开始审视科学研究时——科学界已经有了很多回顾研究，并且再次强调，美国的首席医疗官，也就是美国的顶级医生，发布了关于酒精与癌症之间联系的报告，这种联系在许多常见癌症中变得越来越清晰。我的意思是，仅对女性而言，如果你每天喝一杯葡萄酒，这并不算过量，
just one glass of wine a day, increased your risk of getting breast cancer 40%. And I can't tell you how many young women can breast, I mean, in my practice in Massachusetts in Lenox, Massachusetts, you know, the doctor who I've been working with there for 25 years, she's my medical director, she was 30 years old and she got breast cancer, you know, so this happens and younger and younger women. And I'm not saying she was a heavy drinker. I'm just saying, you know, it happens because the environmental toxins, because the sugar nerd diet or a good microbiome because of the level of alcohols consumed.
仅仅每天一杯葡萄酒，就会将你患乳腺癌的风险增加40%。我无法告诉你，在马萨诸塞州莱诺克斯的诊所里，有多少年轻女性患上了乳腺癌——和我一起工作了25年的医生，她也是我的医疗总监，她在30岁时就得了乳腺癌，所以这种事确实会发生，而且发生在越来越年轻的女性身上。我并不是说她是个重度饮酒者。我只是说，这种情况之所以发生，是因为环境毒素、因为垃圾食品饮食、因为由于饮酒水平导致微生物组受损。
And when you consume alcohol, for a woman, you're going to increase your estrogen. You're going to create more stimulation of your breast issue and overall estrogen issues. You might affect your periods. It might affect fertility issues. Certainly it affects fertility for men and women. If you're younger and you're drinking, you want to have kids, you know, just be aware that it can certainly affect fertility. and, you know, obviously, aside from all the normal issues of, like, you know, driving and drinking and things like that, which people take to do when they have poor judgment.
当你饮酒时，对于女性而言，你会增加雌激素。你会对乳腺组织产生更多刺激，并引发整体的雌激素问题。这可能会影响你的月经。可能会影响生育问题。当然，它也会影响男女的生育能力。如果你还年轻，正在饮酒，又想生孩子，你知道的，一定要意识到这肯定会影响生育。而且，你知道的，除了所有诸如酒后驾车之类由于判断力差而导致的常见问题之外，
I mean, there's a reason you can't rent a car until you're 25. The insurance companies know that you're not mentally an adult until you're 25 years old, then you're going to make poor judgment and have poor decision making, which is going to reach a risk of having a car accident. So they don't want to have that. Yeah. It's so absolutely true. and I always like to tell people about this study. So I'm sure you remember back in the day when they were like one glass of wine, the antioxidants, it actually makes people healthier.
我的意思是，你25岁之前不能租车是有原因的。保险公司知道，你在25岁之前在精神上还不是一个成年人，你会做出糟糕的判断和决策，从而增加发生车祸的风险。所以他们不想承担这个风险。这绝对是千真万确的。
And they talked about this. Yeah, and they talked about this study of like, we compared 10,000 people who don't drink and 10,000 people who do drink. And the people who do drink, they're healthier, they're living longer. You should drink alcohol. Firstly, that study was funded by an alcohol lobbying body, so let's get that out of the way. And secondly, the other huge thing to note, the people in the non-drinking category, have a thought, just a quick ponder, why people would not be drinking at all. Either they don't like alcohol, the abstinent maybe for religious reasons, or they've previously really abused alcohol and now they have to go back to zero.
我总是喜欢和人们分享这项研究。所以你们肯定还记得当年他们说每天一杯葡萄酒，其中的抗氧化剂实际上能让人更健康。他们当时就是这么说的。是的，他们谈到了这样一项研究：我们比较了10,000名不喝酒的人和10,000名喝酒的人。结果发现喝酒的人更健康，他们活得更长。你应该喝酒。首先，这项研究是由一个酒精游说团体资助的，所以我们先明确这一点。其次，另一个需要注意的巨大问题是，不喝酒那一组的人——大家可以想一想，思考一下为什么有些人会完全不喝酒。要么他们不喜欢酒精，可能由于宗教原因而禁戒，要么他们以前曾经严重滥用酒精，现在不得不彻底戒酒归零。
And so they didn't actually limit their sample to remove these individuals. So they were basically, I don't want to say spoiling, but yeah, let's just use, for lack of a better word, spoiling that second, that first group and pulling down the average health of the first group. So it looked like the non-drinkers were less healthy. But it was actually because some of the people in that group had been abusing alcohol for so long. And now it's such a, it's this study that is like huge, you know, you hear it even referenced in pop culture. Like there's an episode of the office where they talk about it. There's an episode of parks and recreation.
因此，他们在采样时并未剔除这部分人群。所以他们实际上可以说是（虽然我不想用“污染”这个词，但为了缺乏更好的词）污染了第二组、不，是第一组，拉低了第一组的平均健康水平。因此，看起来不喝酒的人似乎没有那么健康。但实际上是因为该组中的一些人长期酗酒。如今这成了一项巨大的研究，你知道的，你甚至能在流行文化中听到对它的引用。比如《办公室》（The Office）里有一集就谈到了这个。还有《公园与游憩》（Parks and Recreation）里也有一集。
It's one of those studies, you know how every now and again a study will just like enter the psychobabble and like enter our collective dialogue? And we're being like, oh, have you heard about this? But I think when I really started looking at that study, I was like, oh, so alcohol is this like huge thing that no one's telling me about. And it's so funny because it links so much with community. Oftentimes out. It's like social, right. Social drinking. What advice would you have there?
这就是那种研究，你知道每隔一段时间，某项研究就会进入心理学俚语并进入我们的集体对话中吗？然后我们会说：“哦，你听说过这个吗？”但我想，当我真正开始审视那项研究时，我心想：“哦，原来酒精是这样一个没有人告诉我真相的庞然大物。”这太有趣了，因为它与社区有着如此紧密的联系。通常情况下，这就像是一种社交活动。社交饮酒。你有什么建议吗？
You know, for 20-somethings, so much of our socializing revolves around booze. It's interesting to say that because, you know, I think there's a growing movement, and I don't know if it's occurring in Australia, but it's certainly the United States of a psychedelic renaissance, which is. that have very low toxicity or no toxicity. You know, like you basically can't kill yourself on them. Although, you know, a friend of mine literally just sadly told me that his wife, his ex-wife, well, soon to be his ex-wife, just drank herself to death, literally just poisoned
对于20多岁的年轻人来说，我们的社交活动中有很大一部分都围绕着酒。说得很有意思，因为，你知道的，我认为有一个不断增长的运动——我不知道这是否发生在澳大利亚，但在美国确实存在——那就是迷幻剂复兴（psychedelic renaissance）。
herself with alcohol. You can't do that with psychedelics, whether it's LSD or psilocybin or MDMA. there's a lot of renaissance in terms of both research and the application of these compounds, both in a therapeutic setting, but also in a social setting. I'm seeing more and more people who are moving away from alcohol and more towards these substances, which are in theogens, they're connecting drugs. They're not things that are, you kind of get into a depressive stupor. I mean, alcohol is a depressant.
它们的毒性非常低或没有毒性。你知道的，基本上你不会因为它们而死。尽管，你知道的，我的一位朋友刚刚悲伤地告诉我，他的妻子——他的前妻，或者说即将成为前妻的妻子——刚刚因酒精中毒而死，字面意义上就是用酒精把自己毒死了。你用迷幻剂是做不到这一点的，无论是LSD、裸盖菇素（psilocybin）还是MDMA。在科学研究和这些化合物的应用方面都有很多复兴，无论是在治疗环境中，还是在社交环境中。我看到越来越多的人正在远离酒精，转向这些物质，它们是神圣内生剂（theogen），是连接类药物。它们不会让你陷入抑郁昏迷。我的意思是，酒精是一种抑制剂。
You become stupid and you become depressed as opposed to these other categories of drugs, which are fun and you can enjoy a great time. and you can also use them for therapeutic reasons for post-traumatic stress disorder depression. I mean, psilocybin major papers published in major journals like the New England Journal or the Journal of the American Medical Association or their key journals showing that this is a better therapy
你会变得愚蠢，变得沮丧，而这些其他类别的药物则很有趣，能让你度过一段美好的时光。而且你还可以将它们用于创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）和抑郁症等治疗原因。我的意思是，裸盖菇素在《新英格兰医学杂志》或《美国医学会杂志》等各大期刊上发表了重要论文，这些核心期刊显示，
for resistant treatment problems like PTSD or depression than any drug ever discovered or studied. And by orders of magnitude, not just by like 10%, but like two or three times better. you know, when we see a big effect, go, oh, it's a 20% improvement of this or a 20% risk of that, that's fine. But like when you talk about a two or 300% increase benefit, then that's something real. So I think we have to sort of rethink how to have fun.
对于难治性问题（如PTSD或抑郁症），这种疗法比人类发现或研究过的任何药物都要好。而且是成倍地好，不仅仅是好10%，而是好两到三倍。你知道的，当我们看到一个显著的效果时，会说：“哦，这个指标改善了20%，那个风险降低了20%”，这很好。但当你谈到200%或300%的收益增长时，那才是真正有意义的。所以我想我们必须重新思考如何获得快乐。
And alcohol is, I mean, I was lucky because when I was 18, I went out West and Canada to work on an oil rig kind of exploration company. and, you know, I was young, I was 18, and I never really drank much at all. And I had a few times in high school, but, and these guys were sort of egging me on the bar in the middle of nowhere and the Bloody Union Reservation in Alberta. And they were egging me on to just drink more and more beer and some kind of stupid game they were playing. And I just did it. And I got so ill that I was vomiting blood.
酒精是——我的意思是，我很幸运，因为当我18岁时，我去了西部和加拿大的一个石油钻井勘探公司工作。你知道的，我很年轻，当时18岁，我其实几乎从不喝酒。我在高中时喝过几次，但在阿尔伯塔省布卢迪印第安保留地（Blood Indian Reserve）荒郊野岭的酒吧里，那些家伙一直在起哄怂恿我。他们起哄让我喝越来越多的啤酒，玩着某种他们正在玩的愚蠢游戏。而我真的照做了。我病得那么厉害，甚至开始吐血。
I was vomiting all night. I had the worst hangover the next day. And I literally didn't drink a single thing from 18 to in my mid-30s when I had to start having a little wine. Because I was like, I don't, that was like the most powerful deterrent. So I think, you know, I think everybody has to sort of find what that sweet spot is for them. Yeah. Occasionally if you want to have a drink and you're otherwise healthy, if you have a tequila
我吐了一整夜。第二天宿醉得无以复加。从18岁到30岁出头我开始不得不喝一点葡萄酒之前，我 literalmente再也没有喝过一滴酒。因为我觉得，那是最有力的威慑。所以我想，每个人都必须找出对自己而言的那个“甜点区间”（sweet spot）。偶尔如果你想喝一杯，而且你其他方面都很健康，每隔几周喝一杯龙舌兰
or glass of red wine, you know, every few weeks, I don't think it's an issue. It's the consistent, steady use over time. That's the problem. And you feel it. When I was in college, I felt it. Like, I feel healthier now than I did at 18 because I don't drink as much. I just think there are other ways, healthier ways of achieving that. Even like Neutropics, like as well, also amazing.
或一杯红酒，我认为这不是问题。问题在于长期持续、稳定的饮酒。而你会有所感知。我在上大学时就感受到了。现在的我感觉比18岁时更健康，因为我喝得没那么多了。我只是觉得有其他更健康的方法来达到那种状态。甚至像促智药（Nootropics）也很棒。
Even just like this is going to sound just have a diet Coke. I know we don't want all that processed junk, but a diet Coke versus binge drinking or like a Coke versus binge drinking. or like a Coke versus binge drinking, if you want to pick your evils, you know, and you still want to feel like... I wouldn't do that too often either, but yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Maybe because you just get a soda addiction.
甚至这听起来可能有点……去喝一杯健怡可乐吧。我知道我们不想要所有那些加工垃圾，但与暴饮暴食或暴饮相比，健怡可乐与暴饮相比……或者可乐与暴饮相比，如果你要在这些“恶魔”中做出选择，而你仍然想感觉……我也不建议太频繁地那样做，但对。是的，是的，可能会让你对苏打水上瘾。
It is an issue. I mean, you know, I think the advent of the wearables and things like your aura ring, I think it helps people see how alcohol harms their sleep. And I think from my friends and colleagues, it's something I've heard a lot. It's like, oh, I noticed that when I got my wearable, it really affected the quality of my sleep,
这是一个问题。我的意思是，你知道的，我认为可穿戴设备（如你的Oura戒环）的出现，有助于人们了解酒精是如何损害他们的睡眠的。从我的朋友和同事那里，我听到了很多这样的反馈。就像是：“哦，我发现当我戴上可穿戴设备后，我注意到它确实影响了我的睡眠质量，
my deep sleep, my REM sleep, my heart variability, my nervous system was adversely affected by this. And then, you know, when you, when you look at, do that over and over again, you end up with really damaged sleep architecture. That lack of sleep leads to, you know, things like cancer and dementia and heart disease and diabetes and just is bad for your brain. Yeah. I think it accelerates aging when you drink. It can increase risk of liver disease, gut damage, the microbiome gets affected. It's not something I encourage people to do that much of it.
我的深睡眠、REM睡眠、心率变异性，我的神经系统受到了这些东西的不利影响。”然后，你知道的，当你一次又一次地这样做时，你最终会拥有严重受损的睡眠结构。缺乏睡眠会导致癌症、痴呆症、心脏疾病和糖尿病等问题，而且对你的大脑非常有害。是的。我认为饮酒会加速衰老。它会增加患肝病、肠道损伤的风险，微生物组也会受到影响。我不鼓励人们喝太多酒。
Explore some of these other things. Some of them are illegal. Some of them are not. But I'm not going to recommend anybody doing anything illegal. But I think people can sort of choose what they want. And that's really important to understand that there's a renaissance happening. Yeah. And I love that.
去探索其他一些东西吧。其中一些是合法的，一些不是。但我不会建议任何人去做任何违法的事。但我认为人们可以自己选择他们想要什么。理解正经历的这场复兴非常重要。是的，我喜欢这一点。
People can choose what they want. Like it is still at the end of the day, your body, your health, your choices. Just know what you're doing. Yeah, know what you're doing. Do I have ice cream sometimes? Sure. Do I know it's like got a lot of sugar and stuff? Yeah.
人们可以自主选择他们想要什么。归根结底，这仍然是你的身体、你的健康、你的选择。只要清楚自己在做什么。对，清楚自己在做什么。我有时会吃冰淇淋吗？当然。我知道里面有很多糖和别的东西吗？对。
Am I willing to do that? Because life with ice cream just seems so sad. Yeah. Of course. But do I have ice cream every night? No. I mean, do I have it maybe once a month or every couple of months or twice a year? Yeah.
我愿意吃吗？因为没有冰淇淋的生活看起来太悲惨了。当然。但我每天晚上都吃冰淇淋吗？不。我的意思是，我可能一个月吃一次，或者每几个月吃一次，或者一年吃两次？是的。
I mean, I don't really worry about it if it's in the context of overall healthy life. Yeah. The 80-20 rule. We're going to take a short break here, but we will be back very shortly with Dr. McIman. 2%. That is the number of people who, take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
我的意思是，如果在整体健康生活的背景下，我真的不会为此担忧。是的。80/20法则。我们在这里短暂休息一下，很快就会和海曼医生一起回来。《2%》。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理坚韧度的科学，
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
健身，以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养韧性。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透充斥在健康产业中那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们过去真的相信种子油天生会引发炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。名字是字母 T-W-O-Persent，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country. girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target.
任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，绝对不要惹女汉子。玩蠢游戏，就会得到蠢下场。法则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《闺蜜》这档节目的新季度中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个惯犯约会过。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼去吧。我发誓我将是他的最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
他会得到应有的惩罚。请收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击莉姬·金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉姬·金姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那一切的。包括最近一集，马兰蒙特·希尔滔滔不绝地谈论 80 年代的快克毒品。坦白说，84 年对我很重要，不仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时都可以聊聊快克，不过为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？对啊。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我将带来我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里·方丹、雷恩·克拉克。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions.
而我们却还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·布恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要？还是你做个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机。
mentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. So, the question everyone always asks me when it comes to the health in the 20s is about nicotine. We've talked about alcohol. Let's talk about alcohol. Let's talk about. about vaping. Now, this might be, let's just get your general thoughts on vaping because I know, at least in Australia, it was kind of promoted as this way to stop smoking. Yeah. I mean, it's not a cigarette, so it doesn't have some of the harmful things that are in the burning of tobacco. And it's marketed sort of as a healthy alternative smoking, but it's not safe at all. The chemicals and vapes cause all sorts of issues.
说得对，兄弟。完全正确。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们深入探讨疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。那么，每当我谈到二十多岁的健康问题时，大家问得最多的问题就是关于尼古丁。我们聊过酒精了。我们来聊聊酒精。我们来聊聊。聊聊电子烟。现在，这可能是，让我们先听听你对电子烟的总体看法，因为我知道，至少在澳大利亚，它曾被推广为一种戒烟的方式。是的。我的意思是，它不是香烟，所以它没有燃烧烟草所产生的一些有害物质。而且它的营销方式有点像是吸烟的健康替代品，但它一点也不安全。电子烟中的化学物质会导致各种问题。
Lung damage, you get serious pneumitis, and people have ended up in the hospital and had severe permanent lung damage from this. It leads to systemic inflammation your body, cardiovascular risk. Plus, nicotine itself is highly addictive. It disrupts your brain chemistry. It leads to more anxiety and dependencies.
肺部损伤，你会患上严重的肺炎，有些人因此住进了医院，并留下了严重且永久性的肺损伤。它会导致你身体的系统性炎症，增加心血管风险。此外，尼古丁本身高度成瘾。它会破坏你的大脑化学物质。这会导致更多的焦虑和依赖。
You become addicted to it, and you only feel good when you're taking it. you know like a friend said he had a nicotine spray or a nicotine pack that he put in his mouth for you know being alert for something he had to do that's fine once in a while but but vaping is not safe um and it also gives a quick dopamine spike in the brain which creates a cycle of craving and reward and um they're kind of easy they're socially acceptable they babe constantly throughout the day it actually makes you probably smoke quote smoke more which makes the addiction worse And so it's a pretty toxic habit.
你对它上瘾了，只有在吸食时才会感觉良好。你知道，就像有个朋友说他有一种尼古丁喷雾或尼古丁贴片，他把它放进嘴里，为了在必须完成某项任务时保持清醒，偶尔用一次没关系，但电子烟并不安全，而且它会在大脑中迅速引发多巴胺激增，从而产生一种渴望与奖励的循环，并且它们挺容易使用，社会也更能接受，他们整天不停地抽电子烟，这实际上可能会让你抽更多的烟，从而使烟瘾变得更严重。所以这是一个相当有毒的习惯。
And the key is really, you know, looking at how do you get over that? How do you kind of stop a vaping addiction or even use a vaping? Well, you've got to support your brain chemistry. You know, you've got to break the habit. So get rid of the triggers. If your vape is in your pocket, you're going to reach for it. Don't leave it there. You know, you can replace the habit with other habits, right?
关键其实是，你知道，看看如何克服它？如何戒掉电子烟瘾，甚至是如何停止使用它？好吧，你必须支持你的大脑化学平衡。你知道，你必须打破这个习惯。所以要摆脱诱惑源。如果你的电子烟在口袋里，你就会去拿它。不要把它放在那儿。你知道的，你可以用其他习惯来代替这个习惯，对吧？
Things like deep breathing or going for run or chewing gum. And then also you want to make sure you to support your body. brain chemistry. You can take things like tyrosine, which is an amino acid. You can, you know, you support your brain chemistry with healthy fats, amino acids from protein, B vitamins, often very helpful in repleting a lot of things that get damaged during, during use of nicotine. Sometimes behavioral therapy helps or nicotine replacements like Patch is going to help you sort of transition off. Those aren't permanent, though. You don't want to keep doing that. But, but it's definitely not safe. It's definitely not safe. And it's not, I would say it's not even not safe.
比如深呼吸、去跑步或嚼口香糖。然后，你还要确保支持你的身体。大脑化学平衡。你可以摄入一些诸如酪氨酸之类的氨基酸。你可以，你知道的，通过健康脂肪、蛋白质中的氨基酸来支持大脑化学平衡，B族维生素通常也非常有助于补充在使用尼古丁期间受到损害的很多东西。有时行为疗法会有所帮助，或者像尼古丁贴片这样的替代品会帮助你顺利戒断。不过这些都不是永久的。你不能一直用下去。但是，这绝对不安全。这绝对不安全。而且它不是，我可以说它甚至不是不安全。
it's harmful. It's very harmful. And I've seen many people and patients with serious issues as a consequence of vaping on a regular basis. And that's the things that you don't really see as much in the media, right? It's scary, but it's not something that's like coming to the surface. I was speaking to someone the other day who was also an MD, also a doctor. And I asked him, I was like, oh, you know, what do you think is going to be the thing that we look back and go, that was such a terrible idea the same way that we look at Spokey and he was like well it's it's vaping and I have I have
它是害人的。它非常有害。我见过很多人和患者因为经常吸电子烟而导致严重的健康问题。而这些事情在媒体上其实并不常见，对吧？这很可怕，但它并不是那种浮出水面的事情。我前几天和另一个人交谈，他也是一名医学博士，也是个医生。我问他，我说：“哦，你知道的，你认为我们回过头去看会觉得‘那是多么糟糕的主意’的东西会是什么，就像我们看待吸烟那样？”他回答说：“嗯，是电子烟。”而且我
friends who was so addicted to it I had one friend and she has now quit but she was telling me this compelling story compelling slash scary however you see it of how she would wake up in the morning and the first thought she would have was to find her vape and the first
有朋友对它上瘾得厉害。我曾有一个朋友，她现在已经戒了，但她跟我讲了一个引人入胜的故事——引人入胜兼之有点可怕，随你怎么看——她早上醒来，脑子里想的第一件事就是找她的电子烟，她早上吸入的第一
breath of air she would have in the morning was a vaid and she would fall asleep and the same thing so she And she was just like, it was just every, every single day I was so addicted to it. And to the point where she even said, when she knew she needed to quit, was she would wake up in the middle of the night, sweating and feeling like I, craving nicotine. Because her body literally couldn't even do the seven, eight hour withdrawal of sleep. And that's just the thing. It's so addictive.
口气就是电子烟，她入睡前也是如此。所以她就是……她简直是觉得，每天、每天我都对它上瘾到这种程度。以至于她甚至说，当她知道自己必须戒烟的时候，是因为她会在半夜醒来，浑身冒汗，感觉自己渴望尼古丁。因为她的身体字面意思上甚至无法承受睡眠带来的七、八个小时的戒断。这就是问题所在。它太容易上瘾了。
And it, like, it tastes great. they smell delicious it's fruity it's like what's not to love and it's not like a smelly old cigarette an ashtray right it's like yeah um yeah and i've even seen this this strange trend of people going back to smoking to get rid of their vaping addictions which not sure that's a good idea i know so dr mal chyman's advice i'm going to paraphrase you is stop with the vapes. There's no, they're not a healthier, they're not a, they're not a healthy option full stop. They're not like a healthy version of smoking. They're an unhealthy version. It's just creating even different issues. You know, I think, you know, long term we don't know, but for sure in
而且，它，尝起来很棒。它们闻起来很香，是水果味的，就像有什么理由不爱它呢？它不像一根臭气熏天的旧香烟和一个烟灰缸，对吧？就像是，是的，嗯，是的，我甚至见过这种奇怪的趋势：人们为了戒掉电子烟瘾而重新开始抽真烟，我真不确定这算是个好主意。我知道。所以，马尔·海曼博士的建议，我来概括一下你的话，就是别抽电子烟了。没有什么，它们不是更健康的，它们不是，它们根本不是健康的选项。它们不像吸烟的健康版本。它们是不健康的版本。它只会引发更多不同的问题。你知道，我认为，从长远来看我们不得而知，但可以肯定的是，在
the short term, you know, usually people have to smoke for decades to get permanent lung damage. With vaping, it can happen very quickly. And it causes this inflammatory in the lungs that puts people in the ICU on ventilators. So you don't hear that, but I hear that because I'm a doctor. But it's quite a concerning habit. And I would recommend if you're at all care about your health and well-being, there's lots of ways to have fun. There's lots of ways to get dopamine.
短期内，你知道，通常人们必须吸烟几十年才会导致永久性肺损伤。而使用电子烟，这种情况会发生得非常快。它会在肺部引起这种炎症，导致人们被送进重症监护室上呼吸机。所以你平时听不到这些，但我能听到，因为我是个医生。但这是一种相当令人担忧的习惯。我建议，如果你哪怕有一点点关心自己的健康和福祉，有很多方法可以获得乐趣。有很多方法可以获得多巴胺。
You know, personally, my favorite dopamine addiction is exercise. You know, it's like I love to be outside, riding my bike, playing tennis, working hard, sweating. I mean, that just makes me like feel great. And you can get high without having to do a bunch of drugs. Yeah, fantastic advice. Or breathwork even. Breathwork is breathwork.
就我个人而言，我最喜欢的获取多巴胺的成瘾方式是运动。你知道，我喜欢待在户外，骑自行车、打网球、努力工作、流汗。我的意思是，这真的让我感觉棒极了。你不需要嗑一堆药也能嗨起来。是的，非常棒的建议。甚至呼吸法也可以。呼吸法就是呼吸法。
Let me just say this. Breathwork, the first time you do it in particular will make you feel high, drunk, whatever. Like it's actually so insane. I remember the first time I did it. And now it's quite a regular part of my routine. I was at this yoga event. and they brought in this practitioner who does it. And I remember coming out of it and being like, ooh,
让我这么说吧。呼吸法，特别是你第一次尝试的时候，会让你感觉像是嗑了药、喝醉了，诸如此类。这实际上太疯狂了。我还记得我第一次做的时候。现在它已经成了我日常生活中的常规部分。我当时在一个瑜伽活动上。他们请来了一位精通此道的导师。我记得做完之后出来，心想：噢，
I actually feel so like weird. Yeah, and so alive. And I was like, wow, like this is look at my skin, look at my hands. I was like, when was the last time I intentionally breathed? It's so funny you're saying you get paid a lot of money to just tell people really simple things and what is more simple to being a human than breath. I want to take a quick pivot. first thing we do and it's the last thing we do.
我其实感觉好奇怪。是的，而且感觉充满生机。我就想：哇，看看我的皮肤，看看我的手。我想：我上一次有意识地呼吸是什么时候？真搞笑，你刚才说你拿了很多钱去告诉人们一些非常简单的事情，作为一个人，还有什么比呼吸更简单的呢？我想快速转换一下话题。我们做的第一件事，也是我们做的最后一件事。
Take a breath. There we go. That's going to be the quote of the day, I think. Quick pivot. Let's talk about mental health for a second. How do you think our mental health and our physical health intersect in our 20s? What's important about that relationship? It's so huge.
深呼吸。好了。我想这会成为今天的金句。快速转换一下话题。我们来聊一会儿心理健康。你认为在二十多岁时，我们的心理健康和身体健康是如何交织在一起的？这种关系为什么很重要？它太重要了。
I think there's so many people that struggle with mental illness, whether it's depression, anxiety, PTSD, bipolar disorder, or OCD, I mean, the list goes on, eating disorders. And, you know, our understanding of mental health has really changed. And I just maybe take a minute to dive in here because I think it's such an important topic. But, you know, classically in psychiatry, we diagnose people based on their symptoms, not the causes. So if you're sad and hopeless and help us and have no interest in normal activities and can't sleep and don't have sex and don't want to eat or you eat too much or whatever, we go, I know what's wrong with you. You have depression. but depression is not the cause of those symptoms. It's the name we give to groups of people who share those symptoms.
我认为有很多人都在与心理疾病做斗争，无论是抑郁症、焦虑症、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、双相情感障碍还是强迫症，我的意思是，这个名单还在继续，还有进食障碍。而且，你知道，我们对心理健康的理解真的发生了改变。我可能需要花一分钟深入探讨一下，因为我认为这是一个非常重要的话题。但是，你知道，在传统的精神病学中，我们是根据症状而不是根据病因来诊断人们的。所以如果你感到悲伤、绝望、无助、对正常活动失去兴趣、失眠、没有性欲、不想吃东西或者吃得太多，诸如此类，我们就会说：“我知道你哪里不对劲了。你得了抑郁症。”但抑郁症并不是这些症状的病因。这只是我们给那些表现出这些症状的人群起的一个名称。
And the cause of depression can be many things. It can be because your mother just died or because your boyfriend, you know, left you or because something horrible happened. We kind of taken a completely twisted view of mental health over the last, you know, 100 years. And now it needs to change to not sort of blame the person. I mean, if you have an inflammation of your joint, we see of arthritis, we don't, it's not some kind of moral stain on you. But if we say you're mentally ill, there's a stigma to it. There's
而导致抑郁症的原因可以有很多。可能是因为你母亲刚去世，或者是因为你的男朋友，你知道的，抛弃了你，或者因为发生了什么可怕的事情。在过去的一百年里，我们对心理健康的看法完全变得扭曲了。现在它需要改变，而不是去责怪个人。我的意思是，如果你有关节炎症，我们认为是关节炎，这并不意味着你有什么道德上的污点。但如果我们说你有精神疾病，这就带有污名化。这有一种
sort of a moral or sort of, you know, judgmental view of this. It's something wrong with you, right? But as opposed to, wow, this is something that, yeah, there's something wrong, but it's not in your head. It might be in your body. Yeah. And that more and more we can start to tease out these things through lab testing and through medical history. And that's really why I love it. Hormones play a big role. I mean, you can have women know this if they're going through their menstrual cycles.
某种道德上的或者说，你知道的，评判性的观点。觉得你有什么毛病，对吧？但与之相反的是，哇，这是一种情况，是的，确实有些不对劲，但它不在你的脑子里。它可能在你的身体里。是的。而且我们越来越能够通过实验室检测和病史来开始梳理这些事情。这正是为什么我热爱这一点。荷尔蒙起着重要作用。我的意思是，如果女性正在经历月经周期，她们就会懂这一点。
If some women have premenstrual syndrome, you know, it's not you. What is it? Right? You know, you get depressed, you get anxious, you can't sleep, you're irritable. And then, you know, you have your period and everything goes back to normal.
如果有些女性患有经前期综合征，你知道的，这不是你的问题。那是什么？对吧？你会感到沮丧、焦虑、失眠、易怒。然后，你知道的，你来了大姨妈，一切又恢复正常了。
Clearly there's a link between your biology and your psychology, right? Yeah. And what we've missed is that link. And then that's what I spent a lot of my work doing is helping to advance both treatments of the physical body, but also the brain and mental health by really addressing these underlying root causes.
很显然，你的生物学特性和心理学特性之间存在联系，对吧？是的。而我们一直忽略的就是这种联系。这就是我大部分工作所做的事情，通过真正解决这些潜在的根本原因，来帮助推进对身体以及大脑和心理健康的治疗。
So your gut health, your diet, sleep, exercise is so important. And any inflammation from any source, whether it's environmental toxin, and sometimes it's not your fault. Sometimes it's like, you know, you're living in a place where there's no sign, you don't get vitamin D. Or you're some doctor recommended,
所以你的肠道健康、饮食、睡眠、运动都非常重要。还有来自任何来源的任何炎症，无论是环境毒素，而且有时这并不是你的错。有时就像是，你知道的，你住在一个没有阳光的地方，你吸收不到维生素D。或者有些医生推荐了
an acid, you have locking truck because you have heartburn and then you don't have vitamin B12 or you don't like fish and you love omega-3s or maybe you love fish and eat tuna all the time and you have mercury poisoning. All those things cause depression, right? And so you kind of have to individualize treatment based on the root cause. And that's really what we do at Function Health. It's what I do. I've been doing for 30 years with my patients with functional medicine. So it's a really important moment where our whole psychiatric shift, has happened and just completely flip people upside down. I mean, you know, right now it's Stanford University as a whole department of metabolic psychiatry. Chris Palmer at Harvard has, you know,
抗酸药，因为你胃灼热而阻断了胃酸，然后你缺乏维生素B12，或者你不喜欢吃鱼，而你渴望欧米伽-3脂肪酸，或者也许你喜欢吃鱼，经常吃金枪鱼，结果得了汞中毒。所有这些都会导致抑郁，对吧？所以你必须根据根本原因来进行个性化治疗。这正是我们在 Function Health 所做的事情。这也是我一直在做的事情。我用功能医学为我的患者治疗已经 30 年了。所以这是一个非常重要的时刻，我们整个精神病学的范式发生了转变，彻底颠覆了人们的认知。我的意思是，你知道，现在斯坦福大学专门设立了一个代谢精神病学系。哈佛大学的克里斯·帕尔默，你知道的，
done a lot of work on this, wrote a book called Brain Energy, very much similar to the book that I wrote Ultramine Solution years ago, but that was a little bit more in depth around all the various factors to not just metabolic or mitochondrial health. And so, you know, there's a real understanding now at these major academic centers that there's a problem with our psychiatric paradigm and then we need to challenge it. Mayo Clinic just got $3.3 million as a donation to study the effect of ketogenic diets
在这方面做了大量工作，写了一本书叫《大脑能量》，这和多年前我写的《超级大脑方案》非常相似，不过那本书在探讨不仅仅是代谢或线粒体健康的各种不同因素时，要更深入一些。所以，你知道，这些顶尖学术中心现在真正认识到我们的精神病学范式存在问题，我们需要挑战它。梅奥诊所刚刚获得了 330 万美元的捐赠，用于研究生酮饮食对
on mental health, including things like schizophrenia and bipolar disease and even more mild, I would say, called mild. Mild if you haven't, but like, you know, not as serious mental health issues like just depression. So the, the, the, The body has this amazing way of repairing and healing if you allow it to.
心理健康的影响，包括精神分裂症、双相情感障碍等疾病，以及我可以说更温和的一些问题，姑且称之为温和吧。如果你没有经历过，那就算温和，但它们是不像抑郁症那么严重的心理健康问题。所以，身体有一种神奇的自我修复和治愈能力，只要你允许它这么做。
And I think, unfortunately, we get in the way with drugs. And Chris Palmer actually tells a story about how we had a patient with schizophrenia, who we think is one of the most intractable problems we see. And there's no cure for it. And nobody really quite understands it. And yet, we really have this incredible understanding that, that the brain is a metabolic organ. And when he said to this patient of who is schizophrenic,
我认为，不幸的是，药物阻碍了我们。克里斯·帕尔默实际上讲了一个故事，关于我们曾有一位患有精神分裂症的患者，我们认为这是我们遇到的最棘手的问题之一。而且它无法治愈。也没有人真正完全理解它。然而，我们确实对大脑是一个代谢器官有了这种难以置信的理解。当他对这位患有精神分裂症的患者说——
who took drugs that make them get diabetic and obese, the patient was like, I want to lose weight, I don't like being fat. And he's like, well, just, I don't, and he wasn't going to see anybody else. He wasn't seen a nutritionist, another doctor. He wouldn't go anywhere. And he'd only see this one doctor.
这个患者服用的药物让他们变得糖尿病发作且肥胖，患者说：“我想减肥，我不想变胖。”他说：“好吧，只要，我才不，而且他不会去看任何人。他不会去看营养师或其他医生。他哪儿也不去。他只看这一个医生。”
It was a psychiatrist. I don't really know, but I've kind of heard that, you know, as ketogenic ice might be helpful. And he recommended him for weight law. and then, you know, it was like the guy came back and all his voices were gone his head, all his schizophrenia symptoms were gone. Yeah, it was pretty remarkable. I feel like that's going to be the new wave of psychology and mental health.
那是个精神科医生。我其实不太清楚，但我听说，生酮饮食可能会有帮助。于是他建议他去减肥。然后，你知道的，那家伙回来时，他脑子里的所有幻听都消失了，他所有的精神分裂症症状都消失了。是的，这相当惊人。我觉得这将是心理学和心理健康的新浪潮。
But I'm conscious we only have a few more minutes. I want to ask you two final questions. Yeah. That's a big one. You can keep it short and simple, or you can keep it short and simple, or you can elaborate. That's my favorite flavor of ice cream? Yeah.
但我意识到我们只剩最后几分钟了。我想问你最后两个问题。好的。这是一个很大的问题。你可以回答得简短精炼，或者你可以回答得简短精炼，或者你可以详细阐述。我最喜欢的冰淇淋口味是什么？对。
Well, actually, yeah, we'll leave it at the end. Mine's poisonberry. Oh. What do you think is the biggest risk to our health currently as a population, but specifically for 20-somethings, specifically for a younger age demographic? Yeah. So I think, you know, we've come to sort of accept our food supply as safe. as something that has been approved by the government,
好吧，其实，是的，我们把它留在最后。我最喜欢的是毒莓味。哦。你认为目前作为一个人群，特别是对于二十多岁的人来说，特别是对于年轻的人口群体来说，我们健康面临的最大风险是什么？是的。所以我想，你知道，我们已经开始接受我们的食品供应是安全的，是得到了政府批准的，
as something that we shouldn't really worry too much about. But the truth is, the biggest threat to our species, aside from the changing climate and nuclear war, is the obesity and diabetes epidemic that's a result of the amount of ultra-processed food that is in the market. Now, in America, it's 60% of Americans diet. It's 67% of kids' diet.
是那种我们不需要太担心的东西。但事实是，除了气候变化和核战争之外，对我们物种最大的威胁，是市场上大量超加工食品所导致的肥胖和糖尿病流行。现在，在美利坚，超加工食品占了美国人饮食的 60%。占了儿童饮食的 67%。
And essentially, think of ultra-proseless, cost of food as a bucket of food that you wouldn't make in your kitchen, right? You wouldn't make a Pop-Tart or a lunchable or you wouldn't make Doritos or, you know, like, or Cocoa Colos. Gummy bears. Yeah, I mean, maybe I don't know if you can make them. I think if you can listen, my view is like, make French fries, make them at home. You know, like if you want to eat something like that. And so we basically have a food system that is designed to create very, very cheap calories because they're subsidized, both on the front end with subsidization of the agriculture and on the back end by paying for the consequences of people eating that food
从本质上讲，把超加工食品想象成一桶你不会在自己厨房里做出来的食物，对吧？你不会自己做 Pop-Tart 馅饼、Lunchables 午餐盒、多力多滋，或者，你知道的，像可口可乐。小熊软糖。是的，我的意思是，也许我不知道你能不能做出来。我认为如果你能听着，我的观点是：做炸薯条，在家里自己做。你知道的，如果你想吃那种东西的话。所以我们基本上拥有一个食品系统，它旨在制造非常非常便宜的热量，因为它们得到了补贴，前端有农业补贴，后端则通过用
with health care dollars. But it's ultra-processed food essentially is a vehicle for massive amounts of refined sugar and refined starch. And it's also the repository of inflammatory oils, also the repository of additives and chemicals, things like emulsifiers, which we shouldn't even think about. that are almost all the processive. They basically make food a little bit like, you know, kind of creamy and that thickness that they'll put in,
医疗资金来为人们食用这些食物的后果买单。但超加工食品本质上是大量精制糖和精制淀粉的载体。它也是炎性油类的储藏室，还是添加剂和化学物质的储藏室，比如乳化剂，这些东西我们甚至不应该去想它们。它们几乎存在于所有的加工食品中。它们基本上使食物吃起来有点像，你知道的，那种带点奶油味的口感，以及他们会添加的那种稠度，
even thing like almond milk. You go, that's healthy. But if you look at the label and there's emulsifiers like gums, guargum, and, you know, carotene and these things that seem like they even come from natural products, they're harmful. They cause leaky gut.
甚至像杏仁奶这样的东西。你会觉得，那是健康的。但如果你看一下标签，里面有乳化剂，比如树胶、瓜尔豆胶，还有卡拉胶这些听起来甚至像是来自天然产物的东西，它们其实是有害的。它们会导致肠漏。
They damage your microbiome. They cause inflammation in the body. They lead to prediabetes. They spike insulin. They make you hungry. They cause depression. They cause inflammation. And so you think, oh, it doesn't matter if I'm eating junk food, whatever.
它们会损害你的微生物组。它们会引起身体炎症。它们会导致糖尿病前期。它们会让胰岛素飙升。它们会让你感到饥饿。它们会导致抑郁。它们会导致炎症。所以你会想，哦，我吃垃圾食品也没关系，无论如何，
I'm just, my weight's okay. It doesn't matter. It does matter, you know? Like, you know, a lot of times it'll cause you to gain weight and create obesity, but for some people, it won't. But in and of itself, it's probably one of the biggest threats to humanity. I love that answer. Thank you so much.
我的体重还行，没关系的。其实有关系，你知道吗？就像，你知道的，很多时候它会导致你体重增加并导致肥胖，但对某些人来说可能不会。然而，它本身就是对人类最大的威胁之一。我喜欢这个答案。非常感谢。
And when you eat, when you're 20, she's like, I can eat anything. Like, it doesn't matter. Yeah. Yeah. Like, I would have grape nuts and ice cream for breakfast in college, you know? I don't even know what a grape nut is. It's kind of like a healthy-ish cereal. It's like, but it's kind of like a, you know, it's refined grain, essentially.
而且当你二十多岁的时候，你会觉得：我什么都能吃。这根本没关系。对啊。对啊。就像，我在上大学时早餐会吃葡萄坚果麦片加冰淇淋，你知道的？我甚至不知道什么是葡萄坚果麦片。它有点像那种相对健康的麦片。它就像是，但它有点像，你知道的，本质上是精制谷物。
Yeah, yeah. And so I think, I think we need to sort of understand that we're setting the ground for our future selves. And you don't want your future self to regret what happened in the past. You want to set up yourself for success. And that means success at every level. Because if you feel like crap, it's hard to be successful in school. It's hard to be successful at work and pay attention. attention and focus or something called presentism, which is being at the job and not on the job.
对，对。所以我想，我想我们需要明白，我们正在为未来的自己奠定基础。你可不希望未来的自己对过去发生的事情感到后悔。你想为自己的成功做好铺垫。这意味着全方位的成功。因为如果你感觉糟糕透顶，你就很难在学业上取得成功。你很难在工作上取得成功、保持注意力和专注，或者出现一种叫做“出勤主义”的现象，也就是人虽然在岗位上，但心不在焉。
It's hard to have a good quality relationship because you're disregulated. You can feel gross all the time. Yeah. So there's an immediate dividend. It's not like you're just doing this for your 60 or 70 year old self. You're doing it for yourself now so you can feel good now and not walk around with what I call FLC syndrome. That's when you feel like crap or a more serious version.
你很难维系一段高质量的亲密关系，因为你处于失调状态。你会觉得自己整个人都不好了。是的。所以这里有即时回报。这不只是为了你六十岁或七十岁的自己才这么做的。你是为了现在的自己而做，这样你现在就能感觉良好，而不是顶着我称之为 FLC 综合征的状况四处游荡。那就是当你感觉糟透了的时候，或者更严重的版本。
It's called FLS. That's when you feel like shit. So, you know. Very daily. And those are real things. And I think it's important for people to sort of try. You know, we created the 10-day detox diet, which is really great. And you can go to 10-day detox.com, just the number 10-day detox.
这叫做 FLS。那就是当你感觉像屎一样的时候。所以，你知道的。这很日常。这些都是真实存在的事情。我认为人们去尝试一下很重要。你知道，我们创造了 10 天排毒饮食法，这真的很棒。你可以访问 10daydetox.com，就是数字 10-day detox。
And it guides you through a program that is just remarkable. Just read the testimonials. So I've done this with tens of thousands of people over 20 years. And essentially takes it all the bad stuff, puts in all the good stuff. And then you see, like, how do you set your body back to its original factory settings? do you have rashes all over your body? Do you have migraine headaches? You have irritable bowel syndrome.
它会引导你完成一个非常了不起的计划。看看那些见证反馈就知道了。所以我和几万人在过去 20 年里都这样做过。它本质上就是拿走所有不好的东西，放入所有好的东西。然后你会看到，如何将你的身体重置回原始的出厂设置？你全身都有皮疹吗？你有偏头痛吗？你有肠易激综合征吗？
You can't sleep. You're depressed. Whatever the symptom is, there's been a 70% reduction of all symptoms from all diseases when people do this for 10 days. Now, sometimes people don't get all the way better because, you know, they might have serious. Like they might have Lyme disease or they might have mold or they might have mercury in their system or some more significant thing they need to treat.
你失眠吗？你抑郁吗？无论是什么症状，当人们坚持这样做 10 天后，所有疾病的所有症状都减少了 70%。现在，有时人们并没有完全彻底康复，因为，你知道的，他们可能患有严重的疾病。比如他们可能得了莱姆病，或者他们可能接触了霉菌，或者他们体内有汞，或者需要治疗更严重的问题。
But for most people, it's like, boom, hit the factory reset. And when your computer's not working, you just restart it and it works, right? Yeah. Or in the appliances and working, you unplug it and plug it back in. And so it's sort of like that. And then you can decide, oh, this is how I could feel. I could feel really great. I could cure my FLC syndrome or FLS syndrome.
但对大多数人来说，这就像是：轰的一声，点击出厂重置。当你的电脑出故障时，你只要重启一下它就能正常工作了，对吧？是的。或者当家电出故障时，你拔掉插头再重新插上。所以它有点像那样。然后你可以决定：“哦，原来这才是我的正常状态。我可以感觉真的很好。我可以治愈我的 FLC 综合征或 FLS 综合征。”
And, you know, I really like ice cream. So I'm going to, I've noticed that dairy causes me to have issues. But I don't really care because if I get pimples and a sunny nose and my stomach's upset, it's worth the tradeoff for a once or twice. a month or something. So then you can be educated about how this stuff's affecting because most people have no idea the connection between what they eat and how they feel. And I think it's so important for people to make that connection. So that's why I recommend that. And I'll also recommend for people to start to learn about their bodies early on and track it over time. We've got one more question.
而且，你知道，“我真的很喜欢冰淇淋。所以我要，我注意到乳制品会给我带来问题。但我其实不在乎，因为如果我长青春痘、流鼻涕、胃不舒服，偶尔一两个月吃一次，这个代价还是值得的。”所以你可以通过了解这些东西是如何影响你的来获得知识，因为大多数人根本不知道他们吃的东西和他们的感觉之间有什么联系。我认为人们建立这种联系非常重要。这就是为什么我推荐这个。我还要建议人们尽早开始了解自己的身体，并随着时间推移进行追踪。我们还有一个问题。
This is the question I ask all of my guests. What is your biggest piece of advice for people in their 20s that has nothing to do with what we talked about today? So nothing to do with physical health, just advice in general. You know, in my house today, my best friend came and we met on top of a mountain when we were 18 years old and been my best friend for almost 50 years. And we invest in our friendship. We invest in time together. We stay current. And I do this with many people because I think our social relationships and connections are so important. And I don't mean like on social media or by text. I mean, in-person, deeply connected experiences
这是我问所有嘉宾的问题。对于二十多岁的人，你有什么最重要的建议，是和我们今天聊的话题完全无关的？也就是说跟身体健康没关系，纯粹是一般的建议。你知道，今天在我家里，我的最好朋友来了。我们在 18 岁时在山顶相遇，他做了我近 50 年的最好朋友。我们投资于我们的友谊。我们投资于共度的时间。我们保持紧密联系。我和很多人都这样做，因为我认为我们的社交关系和连结非常重要。我指的不是在社交媒体上或通过发短信。我指的是面对面、深度连结的体验，
where you put your phones away and you show up and you're present in the moment with people and get the true experience of what it is to be in connection and community because that's medicine. And I worry that the younger generation is just stuck on their phone like this
在这些体验中，你放下手机，全身心投入，与他人当下同在，获得身处人际连结和社群之中的真实体验，因为这就是良药。我担心年轻一代只顾着像这样盯着手机，
or on TikTok or Instagram or chatting with their friends and don't even know how to pick up the phone to make a phone call. I mean, you can FaceTime someone, that's okay, that's better than, you know, not, but actually in-person time that you invest in is going to pay off so much in the future. And I see so much loneliness, so much isolation. So many people have prioritized their careers and their work over their friends and their family.
或者刷 TikTok、Instagram，或者和朋友聊天，甚至连拿起电话打个语音电话都不会。我的意思是，你可以和别人视频通话，这没关系，这总比，你知道的，完全没有要好，但你投入时间的面对面相处，在未来会获得巨大回报。我看到了太多的孤独，太多的孤立。许多人把他们的职业和工作置于朋友和家人之上。
And at the end of the day, you know, in your deathbed, you're like, you're not going to go, well, I'm glad I emptied out my inbox. You know, or, you know, I'm glad I did that extra whatever was at work. You're going to remember those special moments with people. And I think life is really about creating happy memories. And so invest in creating those memories with your friends and your community. Oh, I'm in a hundred percent agreement. I've got to ask, what's your favorite ice cream flavor?
到头来，你知道的，在你的临终病榻上，你不会说：“哦，我很高兴我清空了收件箱。”你知道的，或者：“我很高兴我在工作上多做了那些乱七八糟的事。”你会记住那些与人们共度的特殊时刻。我认为生活其实就是关于创造快乐的记忆。所以，投资于和你的朋友以及社群共同创造这些记忆吧。噢，我百分之百同意。我必须问一下，你最喜欢的冰淇淋口味是什么？
For the people who've made it as far. It depends. It depends. I had one and now I got a new one. So my previous one was Chunky Monkey, Ben and Jerry's. I love Chunky Monkey because I love the banana and the walnuts and the chocolate. I love Chunky Monkey. Yes.
对于听到这里的听众。这得看情况。这得看情况。我以前有一个，现在我有了个新的。所以我之前的最爱是本杰瑞的“胖猴子”（Chunky Monkey）。我喜欢“胖猴子”，因为我喜欢香蕉、核桃和巧克力。我喜欢“胖猴子”。是的。
There's a version of ice cream in America called Van Lewins. It's kind of a premium ice cream, but they have a Sicilian pistachio, which I really like. That's so bougie. Those are my guilty pleasures. I'll have to try that next time. I'm in the U.S., but Chunky Monkey is my favorite Ben & Jerry's flavor. And it's not the same as Benofi Pie. It's not the same.
美国有一种名为 Van Leeuwen 的冰淇淋。它算是一种优质冰淇淋，但他们有一种西西里开心果味，我真的很喜欢。这太装腔作势了。这些都是我的小小罪恶之乐。下次我在美国时我得尝尝这个。不过“胖猴子”是我最喜欢的本杰瑞口味。它和香蕉拖肥派（Banoffee Pie）可不一样。不一样。
No. Like the Benofi Pie flavor. Well, if you made it this far, drop a comment of an ice cream emoji below so that we know that you know the fun fact of the day. And I just want to thank you again, Dr. Mark Hyman, for coming on the show and for giving us such invaluable advice for free, which is just crazy. My pleasure. My pleasure. I'll link everything below your podcast.
对。“香蕉拖肥派”那个口味。好吧，如果你听到了这里，请在下方评论区留下一个冰淇淋的表情符号，这样我们就知道你了解了今天的趣味冷知识。我只想再次感谢马尔·海曼博士来到节目中，为我们免费提供了如此宝贵的建议，这简直太疯狂了。我的荣幸。我的荣幸。我会在你的播客下方附上所有链接。
And I really would recommend following Dr. Mark on Instagram. If you just want some, like, really great facts on your feed for how to take better care of yourself, it's remarkable. And health hacks, are you still doing health hacks? Or is it just as Mark Hyman? The Dr. Hyman's show, and we created the Hyman Hive, which is a community where people can actually support each other and change their behavior together and learn together. And so it's called the Hyman Hive. There's something for everyone.
我真的强烈建议大家在 Instagram 上关注马尔博士。如果你只是想在信息流里看到一些非常棒的、教你如何更好地照顾自己的干货，那真的很了不起。还有健康小窍门，你现在还在做健康小窍门吗？还是只用马尔·海曼的名字？“海曼博士秀”，我们还创建了“海曼蜂巢”（Hyman Hive），这是一个社区，在这里人们可以互相支持、共同改变行为并一起学习。所以它叫“海曼蜂巢”。这里面总有一款适合你。
I honestly, I promise you that, but I'll make sure that's all down below. And lovely listeners, make sure that you leave a five-star review. Follow along. Follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very, very soon.
我真的，我向你保证这一点，但我会确保这些都在下方列出。亲爱的听众们，请务必留下五星好评。关注我们。在 Instagram 上关注我们 @That Psychology Podcast。直到下次，注意安全。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。名字是 TWO.%（2%），在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。
On the Look Back at it podcast For 1979 That was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year
在《Look Back at It》播客中……对于 1979 年来说，那对我而言是个重要时刻。84 年对我而言意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，
unpack what went down And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends Fellow comedians and favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year I don't think there's a more important year for black people
剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那一切的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起，比如马兰蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。我不认为还有更重要的年份了。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to Look Back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Keir Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean
请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何其他地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你有这个能力，
that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
就代表你需要这么做。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你篡改了这份特定的测试结果两次，对吗？我篡改了一次测试结果。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过相同事情的男子。
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。